hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zur einem spontanen und kari
antwortet auf dem rockefeller center in
new york
es ist jetzt unser letzt unsere letzten
stunden in new york haben angefangen
weil er ist easy in drei stunden fahren
wir nach washington dc wo wir morgen
einen workshop haben und wir dachten wir
beantworten mal wieder ein paar
zuschauer fragen heute ist freitag ihr
habt lange kein kari antwortet gesehen
und hier ist ein spontan carey
antwortete sie unsere erste frage die
erste frage ist ob videos mit damals
meint bob guckt überrascht zurecht und
diese frage ist ziemlich scheiße oder
sagen wir mal ist es ein ziemlicher
scheißtag wir waren sehr überrascht vor
zwei wochen haben wir unser neues video
mit danach veröffentlicht und dort gab
es einige kommentare die sich über das
akzent beschwert haben und ehrlich
gesagt finde wir diese kommentare etwas
scheiße weil jeder von uns hat einen
akzent wenn er eine sprache lernt und
jeder von uns sollte es trotzdem
schätzen wenn jemand versucht eine
sprache zu sprechen
also spart euch doch einfach diese hat
kommentare nächste sie haben wir noch
eine schöne nachfrage ja leider auch
noch mal in die richtung dass akzent ist
katastrophal die aussprache sollte sie
mal von anfang an lernen schreibt nur
fans aber das ist doch ein fenster im du
doch erstmal die aussprache jan schmidt
sauer
okay wir haben aber so schön ausblick
wir lassen uns mal was positives
erzählen sie
von lilo halo spiel spaß in den usa ich
frage mich so was er ausgemacht ich
meine beruflich natürlich noch mal
vielen dank für ihre hilfe obwohl ich in
deutschland nicht wohnen
dank ihrer arbeit kann ich es quasi
erleben ich hoffe wirklich euch künftig
persönlich zu treffen
die kannst du mit uns beantworten bravo
westen dann ja total 19
sie glaube ich wir sind alle
enthusiastisch und parteien aufgebracht
was machst du eigentlich beruflich ich
bin ein video prozent oder ein
hausmeister das beste wahl wenn man in
die usa einreist dann muss man ja sagen
was man beruflich macht und es war sehr
sehr witzig weil manchmal wird das sehr
streng kontrolliert die amerikaner
wollen ja nicht dass wir hier
untertauchen oder heimlich hier bleiben
und dann sind wir eingereist und an der
grenze fragte der typ janisch als ob er
sich das gerade ausgedacht hat es ist
das inventar des job das war sehr sehr
witzig größere trotzdem reinkommen
japanisches hauptsächlich videoproduzent
und ich bin eigentlich product manager
bei einer ngo die heißt ego experience
will machen kultur austauschprogramm und
es ist hat sehr viel zu tun mit dem was
wir auch bei sehr gutes machen ja und
nebenberuflich bin ich youtube-star das
sage ich jetzt immer das ist meine
vorstellung nehmen beruflich bin ich
youtuber easy was bist du eigentlich
auch doof ich bin event-managerin haben
beruflich in köln er das auch geklärt
als nächstes haben wir
von universe der typ im video ist doof
ich kann mir nicht überraschend weil er
ein amerikaner ist meiste was man
universe du bist du wenn du schreibst
der typ ist nova amerikaner ist es ist
einfach und das ist schublade und kacke
du bist du bist der einzige dale office
wie sie haben wir noch einen kommentar
ja da kommt noch was heute viele hass
kommentare ausgesucht hast du aber jetzt
kommt erstmal richtig sauer das ist eine
interessante frage denn tatsächlich
haben wir nach 25 jahren
wiedervereinigung juni fiction gibt es
immer noch unterschiede zwischen west-
und ostdeutschland es gibt zum beispiel
einkommensunterschiede es gibt auch ein
bisschen kulturelle unterschiede
es gibt dialekte die leute sprechen
anders
und ja leute nutzen das manchmal wenn es
irgendwie schlechte stimmung gibt oder
unruhe
dann versuchen sie das gegeneinander zu
benutzen dann sagen sie 8 die
ostdeutschen sind scheiße die man immer
schon scheiße die westliche sind scheiße
aber ehrlich gesagt finde ich das
ziemlich doof und das ist eigentlich
unnütz denn jeder gesellschaft gibt es
unterschiedliche gruppen auch in den usa
zum beispiel oder in china oder wo immer
und diese unterschiede benutzt man nur
um stimmung zu machen also wenn es
probleme gibt dann nimmt man die
unterschiede um gegen jemanden jemandem
anderen die schuld zu geben
aber eigentlich ist es schwachsinn ost
und westdeutsche gehören zusammen und
man sollte dort keinen unterschied wie
sie hast du noch ne frage jetzt erst
jetzt wieder besser obwohl es hier oben
so fühlen ich habe heute morgen scheiß
kommentar gelesen die wollte ich
beantworten ja na dann viel spaß dabei
vorlesen
das war eine eine antwort auf unser
video der in hamburg gemacht haben
jemand sidhu ist eine pussy sitzt zu
hause in einem scheiß sessel von einem
scheiß rechner und macht gar nichts in
seinem leben und glaubst dir ein urteil
zu erlauben über menschen die im leben
alles verloren haben und du hast
überhaupt keine ahnung wie diese leute
sich fühlen
die alles verloren haben die vielleicht
ihre familienmitglieder verloren haben
die ihr land verlassen müssen und nicht
wissen ob sie jemals in irland
zurückkommen können und du laberst du
eine verfickte scheiße und es heißt wenn
du so einen scheiß was du bist du bist
du christine keiner das musste mal raus
mehr ist musste mal raus weil wir
kriegen wir machen nur ein video
irgendwie zum thema flüchtlinge und
schon kriegen so viele hassen und haare
ich hasse das ich hasse diese
us-soldaten
es gab aber auch viele nette heraus
sowie wieder was positives klassen immer
noch nicht wir müssen gleich weg
wie fühlst du dich in new york wie lange
solche schlagen
ganze drei stunden rennen in der bar bis
5 uhr hat dann geklingelt wir müssen
aufstehen und um 8 uhr ging es wieder
weiter
kannst du diese frage
ich muss mal wieder ruhig hab ich
zittere schon weil ich so lange dieses
scheiß helfen
so wenn was sagst du dazu zu den leuten
die angst haben ein engländer der angst
hat nach deutschland zu kommen weil er
denkt dort gibt es witze über ihn kennst
du diese situation bin ich auf englisch
auf jeden fall höchste witze darüber
aber mach dir keine sorgen dass die
leute sind ja nicht so böse sie haben
einfach alles in einem wissenden teusch
von uns und das haben wir ja auch
verdient
das war
das ist ja
bisschen dumm gelaufen aber mach dir
keine sorgen du bist nicht
geflügel und also alle sind freundlich
die höchst einfach viele witze und du
musst einfach mitlachen drin ist nicht
gar nicht beleidigen wollen
du musst da durch bender am anfang ganz
traurig wir haben rexit witze gemacht
und dann hat klaus gesagt für jeden
rexit witz gibt es ein euro verbänden
und dann kam mein vater und hat auch
direkt einen rexit witz gemacht und
wären gesagt papa für jeden ein für
jeden witz für ihren rexit willst musst
du einen euro zahlen
und was haben einfach gemacht direkt
zwei euro auf den tisch gelegt und hat
gesagt ich habe jetzt zwei witze gut da
hat wenn sich gefreut wie sie haben noch
mehr verletzte das war alles
das ist nicht live die leute das war's
kari und easy und ben und jannis
antworten vom rockefeller center heute
nur so sieht es hier aus
wir drehen uns eine sich ist ja auch in
einem wunderschönen blick bei uns ist
bob ist der beste mensch in new york
city
er hat uns bei sich wohnen lassen viele
viele tolle menschen begonnen
du bist der tollste war bonn ist dieser
woche aus seiner wohnung ausgezogen zu
einem freund damit wie bei ihm wohnen
können überhaupt du bist unglaublich
dankbar
okay wir leute bis wald schickt uns eure
fragen hier unten drunter
wir fahren gleich nach roher schinken
mit dem bus und machen dort zwei tage
workshop bevor es weitergeht nach
colorado
wir freuen uns auf eure kommentare folgt
uns bei facebook und bei instagram dort
berichten wir jeden tag von unserer
reise bis bald
liegt mir